if you look around our universe you can
see that it is permeated by many shining
Galactic filaments and walls between
them there are vast stretches of the
deepest space hundreds of millions of Li
years in diameter called
voids these tremendous gaps in space
reach such an incredible mindboggling
size that the largest galaxies appear
like grains of sand in comparison and
some Stars burn out completely faster
than a photon travels from one edge of
this Abyss in space to the other even
the omnipresent echo of the Big Bang
dies down in their vast depths which
hold many secrets and Mysteries that
means it's time to go to the very heart
of the great Abyss in space called
[Music]
void
Cosmo the first in outer space
even after many years of studying the
cosmos we still do not know what exactly
is concealed in its depths however even
now it is possible to enjoy a wonderful
Galactic journey across great expanses
of space in a multiplayer online game
Star Trek Fleet
command explore a vast open world
conquer new planets and upgrade your
Fleet to join a spectacular battle with
millions of players around the world get
together a team of loyal allies
including completely new characters from
the latest
update for example the charismatic
engineer trip Tucker will boost the
team's morale while the pragmatic and
tough volcani and Toole will be a
trustworthy asset in difficult battles
these Heroes will definitely come in
handy in dealing with 10 missions from
the new plot update corst Enterprise for
smooth induction into the game we're
giving you a special promo code for
newbies when registering use warp speed
to get a Content pack which grants new
players 10 epic shards of Kirk for free
click the link in the description or
scan the QR code from the screen and set
out on your space
adventure in terms of the vastness of
the cosmos our planet is just a small
rocky fra magment traveling at
incredible speed through boundless
emptiness for billions of years it has
been orbiting the Sun maintaining a
distance of about 150 million km however
the true size of our system is much
larger according to Modern Concepts its
outer boundary which is considered the
far edge of the hypothetical o cloud is
at a distance of about 100,000
astronomical units Beyond this boundary
Begins the vast abyss of the
interstellar vacuum space so rarified
that there is on average only a single
hydrogen atom per cubic
cm the distances between the nearest
stars in our part of the Galaxy are a
matter of a few light years and a photon
that has left the sun can reach Proxima
centu without ever colliding with a
particle of matter this vast void is a
pervasive and integral part of the deep
structure of the cosmos
it permeates the entire Milky Way
separating stars and planets black holes
and white dwarves super dense Paras and
Scattered nebula if you move outside the
Galaxy you can see that it is surrounded
by an even deeper vacuum for example
between us and the Andromeda galaxy lies
2 and A2 million light years of
exceptionally rarified
space this distance is so great that 25
galaxies like ours could fit in it yet
it is filled only with the deepest
Cosmic vacuum and this is only a small
part of the Great Cosmic Abyss the Milky
Way the Andromeda nebula and the
triangulum Galaxy as well as about a 100
of their satellites are bound together
by pervasive invisible threads of
gravity this structure is called the
local group and is a large cluster of
cosmic matter about 10 million light
years in diameter the local group in its
turn is part of an even larger formation
but a relatively small Galactic filament
by the standards of the universe called
the local sheet this flattened structure
consisting of several hundred galaxies
has a diameter of about 46 million light
years and its thickness is roughly 5
million light
years the sheet is also part of an EV
even larger association called the Virgo
supercluster however very close to the
local sheet outter space suddenly
changes its appearance here the usual
colorful universe is harassed by a giant
black abyss known as the local void in
fact the local sheet is one of its walls
the other conventional boundaries being
the Perseus Pisces supercluster and the
Pavo Indus
supercluster at at the same time the
void is divided into conventional Parts
by several rarified Galactic filaments
and wide passages link it into a single
network with a neighboring sculptor and
Hercules
voids due to the cosmological expansion
of the universe and the gravitational
influence of the surrounding matter the
volume of the local void is slowly
increasing at present its diameter is
about 150 million light years and the
distance to the center is at least 70
million light years meanwhile the
nearest edge of this Cosmic void is
located very close to the Earth at a
distance of about 3.2 million light
years due to this proximity the local
void occupies a significant part of our
planet's night sky about
40% the main plane of the Milky Way
containing many bright stars and large
nebula covers the central part of this
region from us still its edges do remain
accessible for observation in
1854 a dwarf spiral galaxy was
discovered a little north of the
constellation Hercules it was dubbed
angc
6503 later with the advancement of
observation techniques it became known
that it is located in the middle of the
local void and its distinguishing
feature is the incredible multicolor
appearance the spiral arms of the Galaxy
are permeated with bright red clots of
heated hydrogen and shining blue nebuli
are Stellar
nurseries the center is obscured by
clouds of cool gas and dust which have a
noble brown color NGC 6503 has a
diameter of about 30,000 light years and
its distance from Earth reaches 17
million light years due to the
gravitational pool of the Virgo super
cluster this galaxy is approaching us at
a speed of about 43
km/s It is believed that his gradual
approach to the local sheet will
eventually saturate its space with
Interstellar hydrogen causing an
increase in Star formation it is
estimated that in a few billion years
time the current number of young Stars
could double and the small Galaxy will
shine with renewed
Vigor the motion aveng GC
6503 is a clear demonstration of how the
voids are likely to have come about it
is believed that the foundations of the
large scale structure of the universe
were laid in the first minutes of its
existence at the time of chaotic mixing
of matter and energy Cosmic cataclysms
of incredible power shook the young
universe forming local compactions and
voids subsequently clots of matter
became Proto Galactic clouds and areas
of space of reduced density became voids
over time the pervasive influence of
gravity intensified this contrast
pulling stars and Cosmic gas into
relatively dense clusters making the
space and voids even more
rarified observations show that the vast
majority of galaxies formed between 10
and 13 billion years ago in addition no
significant differences have been found
found to exist between the age of
galaxies located in voids and those that
form Global
filaments this fact also confirms the
modern theory of the formation of the
large scale structure of the
universe meanwhile allowing for the
cosmological expansion of space we can
assume that with time the local void
will become larger and more rarified and
the Virgo supercluster will gradually
disintegrate into several independent
groups at present it is an association
of about 30,000 galaxies concentrated in
a region of space with a diameter of
about 200 million light years at the
same time the total mass of the cluster
is about 1 and A2 quadrillion solar
masses which is down amount to about a,
galaxies such as the Milky Way the Virgo
supercluster is partially contiguous
with two other galac I superclusters The
Centaurus and Pavo Indus superclusters
at the same time its other side borders
on a vast region almost devoid of matter
it is called the Taurus void and is one
of the largest known Cosmic voids it is
rather difficult to study this part of
outer space the reason is that most of
the Void lies in the soc called zone of
avoidance a sector closed off from us by
the Milky Way plane the bright stars in
our galaxy outshine the fainter and more
distant sources and Interstellar matter
absorbs and scatters their light however
thanks to infrared studies we do have
some ideas about the structure of this
void the diameter of this tremendous
void is about 200 million light years
and the distance to the center is about
150 million light years when observing
the void one is immediately struck by
the remarkably clear boundary between
the relatively empty space and a bright
cluster of galaxies located much further
away it is called the persus Pisces
supercluster and is one of the largest
in this part of the universe a
transision this sharp is characteristic
of dust clouds even though infrared
studies do not confirm their presence in
all probability the clear boundary
between the void and the supercluster is
caused by gravitation but the exact
mechanism of their action Still Remains
to be found out meanwhile it is thought
that the Taurus void like most other
Cosmic voids is not quite as empty as
one might imagine the way light passing
through it is distorted suggests that
this region May hide in its depths Giant
gas and dust clouds the cradles of
future galaxies according to other
hypotheses huge masses of dark matter
the most mysterious substance in the
universe the properties of which are
still not fully understood may be
contained inside the
void according to the most daring ideas
there are clots of antimatter or even
more exotic matter with negative mass in
the centers of cosmic voids nevertheless
despite their boldness these hypotheses
lie outside the boundaries of generally
accepted scientific Concepts which makes
it difficult to verify them
experimentally currently only two
separate Galaxies have been discovered
tucked away in the space of the giant
void one of them ugc
2627 has a spiral structure and
resembles the Milky Way while the second
known as ugc
2629 is an elliptical dwarf
Galaxy both objects are located almost
in the heart of the Void at a distance
of about 185 5 million light years from
us the distance between them is small
and is within a few hundred, light years
perhaps there are other single galaxies
hiding in the space there but the Milky
Way disc does not allow us to see them
meanwhile the Virgo supercluster
together with four other superclusters
forms a giant Galactic filament called
lania Kia it contains more than 100,000
galaxies and stretches for more more
than 500 million light years in
space its gravitational Center is the
great attractor a mysterious
supercluster of galaxies located 250
million light years from Earth in its
turn lanak Kia is part of a vast
Galactic stream and further out one can
see that most of it is surrounded by a
black abyss of unprecedented proportions
the light of distant galaxies is ground
in its emptiness and even the mysterious
and Elusive neutrinos take billions of
years to cross this Cosmic
abys to be honest it is hard to believe
that despite all the development of
observational technology such a gigantic
void was noticed only 10 years
ago the year
2013 the University of Wisconsin
Madison a team of astronomers led by
Professor Amy Barger is working to
determine the distance between
galaxies in the process an unexpected
and staggering fact is
discovered it turns out that lakia and
most of its surrounding superclusters
are enveloped by a cosmic void of
unprecedented
proportions after making calculations
scientists discovered that its diameter
EX exceeds that of any previously known
void the size of the discovered void
turned out to be so enormous that
several fundamental cosmological
principles were
questioned it appears that the universe
is much more elaborate than we
imagined the research done by Amy J
Barger Ryan Keenan and Lennox Co has led
in all likelihood to one of the greatest
astronomical discoveries of recent years
their work has shown that our galaxy
along with its surroundings is located
in the middle of the largest supervoid
known to
science it was named
KBC after the first letters of the
discovery names observations show that
the shape of the giant void is close to
spherical and its diameter May exceed
two billion light
years according to calculations the
Milky Way is located a few hundred
million Li years from the Conditional
Center of the great Cosmic abyss and
about the same distance from its Edge
the discovery of a giant bubble of
emptiness surrounding lanaka helped to
explain the Paradox that had kept
scientists busy for many years the fact
is that all galaxies in the universe are
gradually floating apart due to
cosmological expansion measuring the
speed of this motion allows us to
calculate the so-called Hubble constant
a fundamental physical constant
characterizing the rate of expansion of
space however if we take the Galaxy's
closest to us to calculate the Hubble
constant it turns out that the rest of
the universe is expanding too slowly on
the other hand if we take distant
objects as the basis the Milky Ways
surroundings are moving moving faster
than they should the discovery of the
Void has accounted for a lot the fact is
that the galaxies inside it including
the Milky Way and its neighbors are
constantly experiencing additional
gravitational influence from objects
outside the void this creates an
additional force that gradually
stretches our cluster in different
directions it is also surprising that
the KBC void is so huge that it
comprises not only superclusters of
galaxies but also other voids for
example the local void as well as the
Taurus void a part of its structure it
turns out that compared to other voids
even though KBC looks large it isn't
quite so empty nevertheless according to
calculations even this void is just a
barely noticeable dark spot against the
background of the observable part of the
universe the diameter of the latter
reaching 92 billion light years if we
look at the global map of the universe
we will see a lot of dark spots on it
close to the KBC void in terms of their
size most of them easily fit within the
framework of modern physical theories
While others show surprising and strange
properties difficult to explain from the
point of view of Science and one of the
most noticeable riddles of this kind in
space is the arous supervoid also Al
known as the cmbb cold spot it is
estimated to have a diameter of 500
million to 1 billion light years and it
lies at a distance of between 6 and 10
billion light years from the Milky Way
this means that this formation is one of
the most extensive elements of the large
scale structure of the universe the void
is located in the southern hemisphere of
the earth's sky and occupies an
impressive area on it several times
larger than the full moon however it is
impossible to see it with a naked eye
the cmbb cold spot is visible only with
the help of special telescopes that
study the cosmos in the microwave
Spectrum thanks to these astronomers
have discovered that within the spot
Relic cmbb radiation of the universe is
about 70 microkelvin colder than the
metagalactic average this deviation is
nearly four times as intensive as the
strongest anomaly previously recorded
and its gigantic size makes it a truly
enigmatic object that requires extensive
study it is now believed that trell cmbb
radiation traveling through hundreds of
millions of light years of deep vacuum
is gravitationally influenced by distant
Galactic superclusters this causes the
pervasive echo of the Big Bang to lose
energy making the CMB cold spot appear
appear cooler in images than its
surroundings nevertheless this effect
cannot fully explain the excessive
cooling of Relic radiation according to
calculations the attraction of external
galaxies can account for only a quarter
of the observed deviation it is assumed
that the remaining 75% of the effect may
be due to the impact of hypothetical
dark matter or dark energy concentrated
in the depths of the Void however it is
going to take a while before we can
truly unravel this Cosmic
mystery as we observe the cosmos we see
hundreds of millions of galaxies
scattered in space each comprising
billions of all kinds of stars trillions
of planets and countless other celestial
bodies this infinite diversity creates
gigantic Cosmic structures covering
space with a glowing network but all
this is but glittering dust against the
great void that fills the universe this
void is the true Cosmos mysterious and
dangerous maybe in its depths are hidden
answers to the key riddles of the
universe or maybe there is nothing but
endless Darkness hardly comprehensible
to the Mind Only Time Will show whether
one day we will get to the bottom of its
[Music]
secrets